ich habe einen ganzen Tag lang jeden Zug
bis zur Endstation genommen und bin dann
immer wieder am gleichen Gleis in den
nächsten Zug eingestiegen um ihn wieder
bis zur Endstation zu nehmen und dort
bin ich gelandet ihr könnt ja jetzt
schon mal raten wie viel Kilometer ich
insgesamt zurückgelegt habe am Ende
erfahrt ihr auch wie teuer es war los
ging es von meinem Heimatort mit einer
Eurobahn Naach Bielefeld das war die
Endstation dort bin ich ausgestiegen
eigentlich fuhr dann ein ICE nach Berlin
die Strecke war gesperrt und der nächste
Zug fuhr nach alten beacen dort
angekommen ging es zweieinhalb Stunden
weiter mit Verspätung nach Göttingen da
bin ich dann ausgestiegen und in eine
weitere Regionalbahn nach Einbeck mit
das war ziemlich dumm denn von Einberg
Mitte ging es auch nur noch zurück nach
Göttingen in andere Richtung fahren von
dort aus keine Züge zurück in Göttingen
ging es weiter nach ölzen das hat auch
noch mal zweinhalb Stunden gedauert und
es wurde mittlerweile schon dunkel dann
ging es weiter nach Hamburg ich war
einfach den ganzen Tag in Regionalzügen
nicht einmal in ice bis jetzt und von
dort aus dann aber für 4,55 mit einem IC
nach Hamburg altonner dort bin ich wohl
auf einem reinen ankunftsgleis
angekommen somit fuhren keine Züge mehr
und ich bin in hamburgaltuner gestrandet
diese Reise hat mich knapp 13 Stunden
gekostet und ich habe 581 km in
Regionalbahn zurückgelegt bezahlt für
alle Züge habe ich